mir ist langweilig
mir ist langweilig ich habe keine
Freunde hier und die startet kenne ich
auch nicht ich habe keine Freunde hier
und die startet kenne ich auch nicht
vielleicht sollte ich es mal mit dieser
App versuchen
da kann ich bestimmt jemanden
kennenlernen der hier in der Nähe wohnt
ich öffne die app einfach mal und lasse
mich überraschen
mal schauen was es hier so gibt
[Musik]
der sieht ein wenig zu seriös aus
der sieht ein wenig zu seriös aus ich
glaube dieser Herr würde lieber Geschäft
kleine schreiben als spazieren zu gehen
ich glaube dieser Herr würde lieber
Geschäft kleine schreiben als spazieren
zu gehen
[Musik]
der ist wohl ein bisschen zu alt
naja ich finde ihn sympathisch
naja ich finde ihn sympathisch er ist
wohl sehr gerne er ist wohl sehr gerne
sieht nett aus trotz Übergewicht aber
ich gucke noch weiter
[Musik]
ich denke dieser typ wohnt auf einem
Bauernhof
Bauernhof ich mag Tiere sehr gerne
ich mag Tiere sehr gerne
er mag wohl die Farbe rot genau wie ich
ich glaube mit ihm kann man Spaß haben
lustiger typ
ihm schreibe ich sicher nicht
ihm schreibe ich sicher nicht mit der
Waffe in der Hand und den Gesichtstuch
sieht der ganz schön gefährlich aus mit
der Waffe in der Hand und dem
Gesichtstuch sieht der ganz schön
gefährlich aus
er ist sinnlich muskulös
erst ziemlich muskulös ich denke er
verbringt viel Zeit im Fitnesscenter
oder zu Hause beim Hanteln heben ich
denke er verbringt viel Zeit im
Fitnesscenter oder zu Hause beim Hanteln
heben
er ist genau das Gegenteil von dem
vorherigen typ
verhaeren type sitzt sicher den ganzen
Tag am Computer und sorgt er sitzt
sicher den ganzen Tag am Computer und
sorgt
dieser Junge sieht sehr jung aus
[Musik]
dieser Junge sieht sehr jung aus wir
sind wohl aus der verschiedenen
Altersklassen
erst noch ein Kind wir sind wohl aus
sehr verschiedenen Altersklassen
erst noch ein Kind
[Musik]
da ist ja Rafael aus meiner
Deutschklasse
[Musik]
dass der Rafael aus meiner Deutschklasse
er hat ein tolles Bild
Rafael habe ich bereits kennengelernt
aber vergessen nach seiner Nummer zu
fragen
Rafael habe ich bereits kennengelernt
aber vergessen nach seiner Nummer zu
fragen
ich schreibe ihm am besten gleich hier
in dieser App und frage ihn nach seiner
Nummer
ich schreibe ihm am besten gleich hier
in dieser App und frage ihn nach seiner
Nummer
Hallo Rafael ich bin Lola aus deiner
Deutschklasse
Deutsch Klasse
er hat sofort zurückgeschrieben
vielleicht ist ihm ja auch gerade
langweilig
vielleicht ist die mir auch gerade
oder
ja hallo na
wir haben vergessen die Nummern
auszutauschen
ja super dass du mir schreibst
oh ja super dass du mir schreibst
super dass ich dich hier gleich gefunden
habe
meine Nummer wäre
456789 ruf mich doch gleich an
telefonieren ist einfacher als das hin
und her Geschreibe
und her Geschreibe ich rufe ihn an
ich rufe ihn an
warum sagt mir die Stimme der gewünschte
mobilteilnehmer konnte nicht erreicht
werden
warum sagt mir die Stimme der gewünschte
mobilteilnehmer konnte nicht erreicht
werden
ich habe eine Zahl falsch eingegeben
[Musik]
ich versuche es gleich noch mal
Hallo Raphael ich bin's Nola
danke für deine Nummer
Hallo Nola kein Ding spätestens das
nächste Mal wenn wir uns gesehen hätten
hätte ich sie dir geben können
Hallo Nola kein Ding spätestens das
nächste Mal wenn wir uns gesehen hätten
hätte ich sie dir geben können
mir war gerade langweilig darum habe ich
mich auf der App umgesehen und bin dann
auf dich gestoßen
mir war gerade langweilig darum habe ich
mich auf der App umgesehen und bin dann
auf dich gestoßen
ich habe dir dann auch gleich
geschrieben
naja normalerweise frage ich die Frau
nach ihrer Nummer und nicht umgekehrt
na ja normalerweise frage ich die Frau
aber
schön den Feminismus mal von einer
anderen Seite zu sehen
aber schön den Feminismus mal von einer
das hat doch nichts mit Feminismus zu
tun
ich mache doch nur Spaß
hättest du Lust morgen etwas zu
unternehmen
unternehmen es sollte schönes Wetter
sein
es sollte schönes Wetter sein
ja sehr gerne wir könnten ja gemeinsam
in die Stadt gehen
genau ich kann dir die Stadt und auch
tolle Plätze zeigen
falls du Tiere magst könnten wir auch in
den Zoo oder auf einem Bauernhof gehen
den Zoo oder auf einen Bauernhof gehen
ich mag Tiere sehr gerne eine tolle Idee
wollen wir uns morgen treffen und dann
spontan entscheiden
das klingt doch super
das klingt doch super treffen wir uns
nach dem Mittag an der Bushaltestelle
beim Park treffen wir uns nach dem
Mittag an der Bushaltestelle beim Park
ja perfekt dann bis morgen Raphael ich
freue mich
toll ich mich auch mach's gut
Raphael ist echt nett
Raphael ist echt nett ich freue mich mit
ihm morgen die Stadt zu erkunden
ich freue mich mit ihm morgen die Stadt
zu erkunden
aber heute sollte ich mal meine Kisten
auspacken aber
heute sollte ich mal meine Kisten
auspacken
sonst stehen wir noch lange hier
sonst stehen die lach lange hier
das echt noch viel Zeug drin
das echt noch viel Zeug drin ich weiß
gar nicht wohin mit den Sachen
ich weiß gar nicht wohin mit den Sachen
ich lege einfach alles zusammen in einen
Raum wo es mich nicht stört
dann kann ich es besser einräumen dann
kann ich es besser einräumen
mist ich sehe gar nichts mehr so
mist ich sehe gar nichts mehr so ich
falle bestimmt wenn ich es so versuche
zu tragen
ich falle bestimmt wenn ich es so
versuche zu tragen
es ist doch viel zu schwer so
es ist doch viel zu schwer so ich lasse
es doch lieber erst einmal hier und
Träume es besser hier aus
ich lasse es doch lieber erst einmal
hier und Träume es besser hier aus
was habe ich denn alles hier drin
wieso klingelt mein Handy jetzt wieso
klingelt mein handy jetzt
anscheinend habe ich Nachrichten von den
Personen aus der App bekommen
Personen aus der App bekommen ich schaue
sie mir einfach mal an ich schaue sie
mir einfach mal an
ich kann ja nicht verlieren ich kann ja
nicht verlieren
hallo Lola ich kann nicht nur gut Kühe
melken schreibe mir doch
ich suche noch meine neue Bonnie
Gruß Kleid
ich würde gerne auf was anderem rum
tippen als nur auf meiner Tastatur
ich glaube diese App lösche ich gleich
wieder
wieder das nächste Mal wenn ich Freunde
suche gehe ich lieber nach draußen
das nächste Mal wenn ich Freunde suche
gehe ich lieber nach draußen
im Internet kann man sich nie sicher
sein wer sich hinter einem Profil
verbirgt im Internet kann man sich nie
sicher sein wer sich hinter einem Profil
verbirgt
möchtest du einen kostenlosen online
Deutschkurs machen
bei uns kannst du dein Deutsch Niveau
[Musik]
so lernst du Deutsch Lektion für Lektion
in der richtigen Progression
deutsch lernen mit Spaß besuche jetzt
unseren Kanal Hallo deutschschule
möchtest du noch weitere Videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren Kanal jeden
Sonntag ein neues video